se ve esto como un chantaje esta nueva
condición de Turquía
sí se puede entender como tal sobre todo
porque al final la adhesión a la otan y
la adhesión a la Unión Europea no solo
es que sean dos procesos distintos desde
el punto de vista de las organizaciones
sino que el camino de adhesión en sí es
completamente
diferente y yo incluso diría que el de
la otan mucho más concreto no el proceso
de adhesión a la Unión Europea que es lo
que ahora reclama reactivar el don es
mucho más complejo y lleva mucho más
tiempo
si hay que entenderlo como como un
nordago incluso a las dos organizaciones
tanto a la otan como a la Unión Europea
ahora es un error de Turquía tratar de
ligar los procesos de adhesión de dos
organizaciones que son completamente
independientes
Sí sí que parece sí que parece un error
no es algo que nos tenga que sorprender
por cómo se suele comportar erdogan en
estos en estos escenarios una una
referencia muy cercana que tenemos de su
relación con la Unión Europea es el
acuerdo
del año 2015 en materia en materia
migratoria que funcionó un poco de esta
de esta forma no al final lo que Turquía
Busca son
contraprestaciones y si ankara cede en
este caso en la en la entrada de Suecia
a la otan necesita una contraprestación
necesita un beneficio y para erdogan ese
beneficio pasa por desbloquear las
negociaciones de adhesión con la Unión
Europea que
antes Esteban en punto muerto desde
Ahora sí debemos recordar que Turquía
inició estas conversaciones en 2005 para
ser parte de la Unión Europea pero desde
entonces el proceso sigue sin avance
significativos cuéntenos por qué
bueno fundamentalmente porque Turquía se
está alejando de los valores que
defiende la Unión Europea el parlamento
europeo en 2022 vino a decir que se
tenían que mantener congeladas y esas
negociaciones precisamente por la deriva
autoritaria del gobierno de erdogan que
hay que recordar que ha renovado su
Estancia en el poder hace solo solo unos
meses con lo cual no parece que esas
relaciones que esos vínculos vayan a
cambiar a corto plazo Lo cierto es que
el proceso de adhesión de Turquía la
Unión Europea es el más largo de todos
los que de todos los que hay o de todos
los que hay abiertos empezó con el
reconocimiento del estatus de candidato
en 1999 las negociaciones como dices
empezaron en 2005 y en 2023 están
estancadas es decir será difícil ver a
Turquía dentro de la Unión Europea pero
desde luego lo será mucho más si la
deriva de erdogan se mantiene en los
próximos años bueno y en cuanto a la
intención de Ucrania de ingresar a la
otan ya por ejemplo los líderes como Joe
biden dijeron que kiev podría ser parte
de la organización pero cuando termine
la guerra ya que de lo contrario esto
los obligaría a intervenir de manera
directa en el conflicto con Rusia Pero
porque entonces seguir enviando armas
aquí
bueno porque la estrategia defiende la
otan y que defiende la Unión Europea
también como como organización diferente
que es es la de seguir ayudando a
Ucrania frente a la invasión rusa Y eso
se está manteniendo incluso pese a las
sospechas o los rumores que en algún
momento de la guerra pudo haber de que
se podría dar un desgaste eso estamos
viendo que no nos está dando hace un año
la otan renovó su concepto estratégico
en la Cumbre de Madrid ahora se vuelven
a reunir los líderes en Vila y el
discurso sigue siendo el mismo Es verdad
que hay ciertas discrepancias en la
forma por así decir entre algunos
estados miembros de la Unión Europea y a
la vez miembros de la otan de cómo tiene
que canalizarse esa ayuda de cuánto de
importante tiene que ser el envío de
armas frente a un intento vamos a decir
así diplomático pero la el fondo es el
mismo y es seguir apoyando